this is the city we love and the game we
believe in
and together we are all cleveland
guardians oh my god okay it's so weak
it's so weak it's so weak i'm sorry
there are a thousand better team names
than the guardians
the big culture war moment of the day is
that the cleveland indians
you know like the baseball team they
have now renamed themselves the
cleveland guardians
for no reason in the same way that the
washington redskins renamed themselves
the washington football team
for no reason in 2016 for example the
washington poll
the washington post actually did a poll
of native americans about
washington redskins in which 90 percent
of respondents
said they were not offended by the
team's name
so um yeah how many native americans
were deeply offended by the name
cleveland indians
honestly like i've always found this
completely bizarre if somebody wanted to
create a team
called the new york jews that would be
amazing
like the new york maccabees or the new
york jews i'd be like i'd buy all the
gear
right like let's say it was a football
team would be like the new york jews
beat the new orleans saints sounds
incredible
like i'm wondering where is the downside
here by the way you know what the
cleveland indians were originally named
after
supposedly or allegedly the cleveland
indians were originally named
after a guy named luis sokolexis was of
the penup scott tribe of maine an actual
native american he played for the
cleveland spiders at the time from 1897
to 1899
and he was so popular that they kind of
changed the nickname of the team
to the indians and then they were the
spiders
for a while and uh and then they changed
their name to the indians
apparently because both they wanted to
mimic the boston braves
and also because there had been sort of
this this
upswing and interest in sock alexis who
played for a couple of years
for the for the cleveland spiders so
honestly look of the problems that
afflict native americans in american
society
the name cleveland indians does not rank
and by the way the atlanta braves will
be forced to change their name and told
the kansas city chiefs and and everybody
else
everybody will be named after an animal
until which until such time as we
realize that this is being mean to to
various species
and we stop that and then we'll just
name people after colors right
it'll be like the cincinnati reds and
we'll have like the saint louis blues
and but all the teams will just pick a
color
so the unlucky team it'll be like the
cleveland fuchsia
it'll be like the saint louis mauve
it'll be very exciting stuff
fixing america's problems one team name
change at a time
they got tom hanks to do the voiceover
which means of course it's all american
they're called the cleveland guardians
yeah not not
fantastic the cleveland indian by the
way
their logo basically all they did is
they just substituted
gar for in in guardians
right indians guardians it made it i
guess cheaper for them to print their
merch
so here's a little bit of of what tom
hanks was voicing over for the cleveland
guardians terrible name we hold tight to
our roots
and set our sights on tomorrow
and this is our team that has stood with
our city for more than a century
from old municipal to the corner of
carnegie a team that has seen its own
progress and prosperity
its history flows like the river through
the heart of this city
the history that has given us miraculous
moments
moments that span years and others 22
games
moments that broke barriers and moments
that broke hearts
moments that prove this is more than a
game
we remember those moments as we move
forward with change you see it has
always been cleveland
that's the best part of our name
and now it's time to unite as one family
one community to build the next era for
this team
in this city to keep watch and guard
what makes this game the greatest
to come together and welcome all who
want to join us
we are loyal and proud and resilient
we protect what we've earned and always
defend it
together we stand with all who
understand what it means to be born
and built from the land because this is
the city we love
and the game we believe in and together
we are all cleveland guardians
[Music]
oh god okay it's so weak it's so weak
it's so weak i'm sorry there are a
thousand better team names than the
guardians
the guardians the prison guard like what
are the one of the words that popped
your mind when you hear guardians
like the only good one is batman like
silent guardian or silent protector or
whatever
cleveland guardians and again all
they're doing is they're trying to look
for the homonymic
relationship between indians and
guardians there to try and get them
through this but yeah the cleveland
guardian i love when he's like the
history of the cleveland indians team
is incredibly important to the city so
important that this team
name will now be changed
the club the cleveland indians has a lot
to be proud of they were the first
american league club to integrate
so jackie robinson was the first
baseball player to integrate the major
leagues but the first american league
team to integrate was the cleveland
indians with larry toby and satchel
paige
so that's like a cool legacy is it not
has there ever been an implication that
the cleveland indians name was chosen to
mock
indians as in native americans
no but once again it's all performative
virtue signaling and then when you
notice when you notice that
there's an attempt to paint everything
is historically racist and necessary
necessarily changing when you paint it
that way and then people say well you
know that that's kind of weird and
unnecessary you're like why are you even
noticing why do you even care
i care because you care too much you
cared enough to change it in the same
way that i cared
when when you changed the name of the
washington redskins because if you cared
enough to change it
i care enough to wonder why how about
that
how's this for a title ben shapiro show
subscriber destroys like button with
clicks and logic
i'd watch that make it happen gang